[Music]
what in the [ __ ] is that grease from the
hood
can you stop lying that was not cleaned
yesterday I'm telling you this is grease
from the hood but they haven't gained it
did you have any idea what happened at
that caught fire now do you have any
idea they've caught fire I go what are
you doing
you stop caring that's the sign of an
owner that cares I want an answer I'm
going upstairs what Tommy come down I
want an answer
CJ it's gone I don't know where he went
oh right well I'm convinced
so this place is clean so I want a lot a
quick bacterial test they thought was
disgusting I don't think these vents
have been clean for years time to tell
her did you talk to Ramsay no he came
down here looking for you now turned to
20 he's deemed as sort of clean
respectable anything over 30 is
unhygenic dangerous and this is reading
[Music]
573 come in you were looking for me
sit down what is that this is a very
simple hygiene test anything above 30 is
in the danger zone
okay 573 from the air conditioning unit
I have an answer for that sorry
that's CJ 573 let's do another one
how long's this chair been here I
believe since we bought the place have
you seen the stains on it see the stains
there yeah
just stay here no I've never stayed here
you've never stayed here in 10 years no
wow house he bought hotel you invested
in it with mum and you've never stayed
here I'm amazed 446 and you've got no
idea it's like this what's the bathrooms
like God do you know the shout curves
got bowled on them
no I don't know your housekeeper pointed
it out those hairs there at this rate I
really should be wearing gloves oh dear
shower curtain what five thousand six
hundred and eighty what in the [ __ ]
seriously
I don't have an answer for that
at all five thousand six hundred and
eighty that is the volume of live
bacteria I'm gonna wash my hands
5,000 and the hell's going on I'm gonna
go just check fair one
sergeant's happy anywhere I'm so psyched
you mind
listen got some issues downstairs and
found some pretty horrific stuff I know
your brief Abed I'm sorry I honestly
didn't think I'm gonna put anyone in
here today that's mold underneathh that
is disgusting and I did a bacteria test
I've been doing them all day on my
shower curtain was mold [ __ ] we just
give me two minutes okay
[Music]